institution
we're looking for
good
this density of life so you think so
welcome back to the second to last a
server they will Kevin will continue and
tell us about the electric piece thanks
okay so BA the kind of message of this
next segment of the talk and is to
reassure you that what I've been
speaking about so far along hasn't been
something kind of idiosyncratically
special about uniform random 3 sad
because after all I think the the real
kind of promise of what I've been
telling you about is that it's possible
to understand rich complex realistic
settings that we can't really get
traction on theoretically so I kind of
made that claim to you and then I turned
around and started looking at the the
setting that arguably we can say the
most possible about theoretically so
that might have seemed disappointing and
I guess I did that because that's
probably the single distribution of sac
that has gotten the most attention and
it's probably the place where our claims
can most likely sort of feed theoretical
work so I think that's a good kind of
test bed to begin with but we certainly
wouldn't want to end there so at this
point I'm going to consider both SAT
distributions that arise in practice and
also problems other than sat and so
here's the kind of broad message that I
have for you across the board we found
that empirical hardness models work
pretty consistently almost everywhere
we've tried them and over the years
we've looked at four different problem
domains combinatorial auction winner
determinations satisfiability mixed
integer programming and traveling
salesman problems we've looked at dozens
of different solvers including each
domains best state of the art solvers
and various blackbox commercial solvers
and we looked at dozens of instance
distributions including the kind of
third-party benchmarks that people test
their solvers on and various real-world
data that we've been able to get our
hands on including domains like Hardware
verification computational
sustainability
and we've also looked in detail at the
underlying machine learning and tried to
figure out which kinds of machine
learning approaches are best for this
problem and at this point in the talk
I'm going to pivot from speaking about
regression which is sort of easiest to
think about I sort of ridge regression
which is a parametric model and it is
therefore it's relatively easy to think
about computationally easy to random
forests of regression trees which is a
bit of a sort of Messier nonparametric
but higher performing learning paradigm
that we've typically found is the best
ideas and so I'm in this part of the
talk going to go at a much higher level
of detail and just give you a sense of
what the results look like and because I
am particularly excited to talk to you
about the applications part of the talk
and I don't want to steal too much of my
own time so um here are some examples
for satisfy abilities so here I'm
showing you Hardware verification data
from IBM and spear which is a solver
that is particularly well-suited to
Hardware verification here I'm looking
at the SAT competition which is held
every year it's divided into three
different tracks random handmade and
industrial kinds of data and we just
took everything we threw it all together
into one giant data set the reason
people don't do that is that the data is
so on so different the different solvers
do well in different sets so this is a
particularly heterogeneous and data set
and we looked at many sad which is a
pretty good across the board SAT solver
and here on the left hand side i'm
showing you linear regression on both of
these data sets and on the right hand
side i'm showing you random forests and
at this point i've got root mean squared
error is given here to the extent that
you can interpret them and you can just
look at the pictures and you know what i
want you to take away from this is
random for its really do seem to be
doing a better job of making these
predictions than linear regression is
and but in both cases were we're able to
do you know something reasonable we're
still getting somewhere working with the
same features in both cases but
particularly in this sat competition
case where the data is really
heterogeneous we have very very
different kinds of insta
is in the distribution and this is
pretty hard for a parametric linear
model to work with because you know what
it does in one part of the instant space
sort of Rama files over to what it does
in another part of the space and when
things are really discontinuous that's a
problem so a nonparametric discontinuous
model like random forests I can can have
stronger performance there and you can
see a pretty big qualitative difference
between this figure in that figure over
here now aiming to predict run time
versus whether it's sad or nuns yeah so
for the rest of the talk i'll be
speaking about just predicting run time
yeah sorry what's the vertical boys
what's the digit so this is predicted
runtime this is actual renta on the
picture oh you say what's going on there
oh well so we only ran the solver for a
finite amount of time right so so these
are cases where the actual run times
were truncated we don't actually know
what they were because we had to you
know these are exponentially varying
things we couldn't run it for like six
years to just to get that one point
exactly right you know and so it simple
we have to cut it off that's a problem
in the machine learning because this is
what's called sensor data right my my
true response value is censored all I
know about it is that it's at least I
big and it turns out they're machine
learning methods for learning in an
unbiased way from sensor data actually
comes through actuarial science
actuaries look at a bunch of people and
they they want to predict when you're
going to die and it's very inconvenient
for them that you're not dead yet and
all they know is that you're going to
live at least as long as you have so far
so that amounts to the same kind of
censorship and so they've developed
techniques which we can use for the
happier problem of predicting algorithm
run tun okay so it's right away so much
for sat let me show you something
similar for a mixed integer programming
problems so you know behind these each
of these graphs means a grad student
spent forever writing scripts and
learning how to wrap the solvers and we
generated entirely new features for
mixed integer programming we've got our
cplex license working and then all of
these individual dots are runtimes on a
cluster somewhere that you know we had
to use a thousand computers for like a
month to generate all these points so
you know I can just throw the stuff
around like it's nothing but
but trust me there's blood sweat and
tears behind every one of these graphs
and but but but so what again you see
here for mixed integer programming is
you know again linear regression is
doing something not too bad it's better
with random forests this is the best
picture that I've ever seen here we have
a root mean squared error of 0.02 and
it's not because there's no variation
and indeed when we have the same data
set for a linear regression it's not
like it's a trivial data set but this is
just one where random for us really
nailed it and this is actually a
computational sustainability data from
Cornell that's about habitat
preservation for the red crested
woodpecker so this means that they can
this doesn't mean we can protect habitat
just means that we can predict whether
or not we can protect habitat in you
know whatever um but but so all this is
just meant to say you know here we're
looking at cplex this is milleb which is
a crazy heterogeneous myth data set and
so again you know this seems to work and
finally here's traveling salesman
problem and there's a last kind of
available data and also fewer good
solvers available for TSP and TSP seems
to be a place where our features are
less powerful we honestly we spent less
time thinking about DSP but we don't
really seem to have great features we
have kind of okay features 4 TSP and I
think this is what it looks like when
you have sort of ok features so we're
still not doing bad you know our MSC's
are still under one and but you can see
like now random forests aren't doing
that different from from regression and
linear regression anymore the there's a
little bit more similar but I don't
member i have to look at the paper i
mean you know like on 80 different
things that you know everything you
might imagine about the TSP or we can
look at it together if you're interested
in TSP but off the top of my head i
remember and so but but anyway I mean I
guess the upshot of this is this really
wasn't a story just about uniform data
this wasn't a story just about one
solver this wasn't a story about sat all
of this stuff carries over to these
really very different problems and and
particularly two very different data
sets that have in a real-world structure
they arose in some application actually
important for something and so then we
can do various different
sagacious of kind of the way we build
the models to try to understand more
about what's necessary one thing we can
think about is how the model scales with
the number of data points so in these
plots I'm going to be plotting
correlation coefficient between the true
and predicted run times so that I can
take an entire scatter plot and boil it
down to one number and then look at how
those scatter plots change as I add more
data and correlation coefficient of 0 is
really bad news and one is perfect and
so here and I guess less than zero means
you're anti-correlated jeering actually
really pretty badly so here you can see
how Ridge regression performs as we grow
the number of training points on a log
scale here and you can see that once we
get up to sort of thousands of data
points we're doing pretty well here mini
sat on this this heterogeneous out
competition data and and here's random
forests so you can see both that they do
better which we already saw before in
the large model but they were doing
better than this heterogeneous data but
also that they're much more efficient
about data so we're learning much more
quickly the error bars are coming from
bootstrap replicates of different sub
data sets of the same size and then
here's of other models that we consider
it isn't like we only looked at these
two so we also looked at Gaussian
processes the projected process
approximation of Gaussian processes and
we looked at regression trees and
they're falling in between these two
methods and looking at a different data
set here's a see parts on a
heterogeneous mix of benchmarks and this
is one where the linear regression does
really pretty badly Ridge regression so
it's like flat lining for a while before
it finally manages to get somewhere
still with a lot of variants and in
contrast again random Forrester doing a
lot better so I think if if one actually
wanted to do this in practice we're
pretty confident that random forests are
a good way to go incidentally one reason
random forests are good for those of you
who know something about this learning
method is they can never extrapolate so
they always they're almost like a data
structure that stores the data that
they've seen and so they they do
regression by returning kind of the mean
of a set of points that lives in a leaf
and what that means is it's never
possible for them to give a bigger value
or a smaller value than they've ever
seen before in the data and that's one
of the ways that these
and parametric methods really screw up
they can predict something wildly wrong
and so and that just sort of naturally
falls out of retrogression that's a
random forest that it doesn't make that
mistake and so so far I've been talking
about modeling single algorithms
something that might be interesting to
think about is parametrized families of
algorithms so imagine that I have
various design choices that I might have
made about my algorithm like what's my
restart probability or should I use
pre-processing or not or should i do my
variable branching by the most
constrained variable or the most
constraining variable or yeah I'm giving
you examples that might be continuous or
they might be discreet if they're
discrete there might be ordinal or
categorical and some of them might be
potentially conditional on the values of
other parameters and there might be
things like should i do random restarts
at all and if so what should the random
restart probability be and so we can
define a set of algorithms by some
parameterization like this and just to
add some terminology that i'll use i'll
call a fully instantiated algorithm that
i can actually run that gives predator
values to everything a configuration of
my advice solver so now we can think
about generalizing our models to these
spaces of algorithm families and here we
did a pretty exhaustive analysis in a
paper but here I'm showing you only the
hardest case which is where we trained
on you know various training data as
before and then we tested on both
instances and configurations that we'd
never seen before so we're asking about
algorithms that we never ran before
based on other algorithms that are
similar and instances that we never ran
before and you know notice that the
problems get harder our quality gets
worse but nevertheless like we're still
able to often do not badly so we're even
able to reason across algorithms in a
sort of limited way not not reasoning
about algorithms that no human has ever
crazily thought of before but reasoning
about algorithms within a an infinite
class of candidate algorithms looking
again it's scaling with the number of
data points we see something kind of
similar here that again it's really it's
not
bad and again random for some more
efficient finally we can kind of
visualize how we perform in the the
joint space of instances and and
configurations so here we looked at a
house and randomly sampled
configurations and 383 instances and and
then we we just evaluated on all of them
and hear hear the true runt I've given a
train models these are all new
configurations of instances we hadn't
trained done before and then here's the
the true runtime where we just sorted
this by average hardness and so the
picture kind of looks clean and and so
you can see kind of the landscape for
this problem then you know there's some
instances where dark is easy I think let
me make sure that's right yeah so dark
is it's fast so there's some instances
that are easy for all configurations and
there's some instances that are hard for
all configurations and there's a lot of
instances in the middle where it really
matters what algorithm configuration you
choose sometimes it's going to be fast
and sometimes it's going to be slow and
you can see there's kind of a structure
to it there's sort of a shape that this
thing takes on and so um right and and
so then here is our predicted runtime
using the random forest and I guess I
just want you to notice that you know
more than just kind of getting a summary
statistic like root mean squared error
or something right you're really
capturing some of the structure of this
landscape with with the model prediction
we look at other models this is
regression trees this is the projected
process approximate gaussian processes
and this is riddled russian so you see
you know they're all sort of doing
something but it's it's a lot less
accurate you get it sort of finer grain
sense of how the differences are here's
random forest again and and finally i
guess here again i'm showing you random
forest now i want to say what if we
trained only on 100 data points here's
how it degrades back to the original one
and here's if we looked at only the one
most important feature and the one most
important parameter and you see that
we're so instance feature we
characterize the instances using only
one feature and we allowed
on the model only to care about
variation in one parameter even though
there was variation in all the
parameters in the the test data and you
see we're actually able to capture a lot
of the structure that so so this tells
us that sort of the higher order story
here on this particular data set of
spear for software verification is
captured in this low dimensional way so
that's all I want to say about that but
I just want to give you some sense of
our ability to visualize this and so
give you some kind of visual picture
about it and but now I want to move over
to applications so so now I want to kind
of ask that as you can see we've done a
lot of different things in the sort of
space of applications I want to ask you
know so much for beyond worst-case
complexity to sort of answering these
philosophical questions about what makes
algorithms hard in a more kind of
practical way what can we you you know
what can we benefit from knowing that
it's possible to predict something about
how long an algorithm will take to run
you know in what ways can that change
our design of algorithms in practice and
first of all let me remind you of
Moore's law because it's always nice
when you look at a practical computer
science talk to to see a graph of
Moore's law here it is and it's it's
important in particular to remember that
you know this cyan line here is the rate
of growth in clock speeds over years on
the x-axis here so graph from The
Economist just from a few months ago and
you know what you can see is that ever
since sort of two thousand sort of early
2000s the computer on your desk has not
been getting any faster read the clock
speeds on individual chips have pretty
much flatlined for you know reasons that
have to do with physics and like there's
a problem with heat and there's a
problem with the speed of light and
there's only so much that you can do
about these things so so but what they
have been able to do is get much more
parallel and get much lower power which
means that we can still pack more and
more transistors on a chip so the number
of transistors on a trip has been
marching along and according to Moore's
law you know unabated even as we've had
this sort of lived experience of
computers not really getting much faster
and didn't know this was full disclosure
this was from an article about how
Moore's Law is going to end you know
there's
of a Moore's law about the every year
there will be twice as many articles
about how Moore's Law is going to end
anytime now so you know any day now but
but at least you know and there in the
recent past there's been this steady
increase in in semiconductors on trips
and what that means is as much as we
might have kind of forgotten about it
things that your algorithmic approaches
that might have seemed really stupid not
that long ago are starting to become
feasible we can really do absolutely
crazy approaches of just throwing insane
amounts of computation at a problem that
would have been prohibitively dumb not
very long ago because of this
exponential growth and I argue that's
what deep learning is all about so deep
learning you know let me give you sort
of a as optimistic of you of deep
learning as I think it's possible to
give right so the classical approach
said let me come up with features based
on expert insight let me go to nips and
understand deeply what's the fashionable
machine learning model du jour let me
learn how to use that let me manually
turn hyper parameters in some clever way
and I'll build a machine learning
algorithm that works well but so the
deep learning approach says let me take
machine learning models from the 80s
that are extremely highly parameterised
just neural networks with gazillions of
parameters let me use expert knowledge
very little just to identify appropriate
invariances and model biases like maybe
convolution is going to be important in
images things like that and make deep in
the sense that I have many many layers
of nodes of notes being things that
carry parameters each depending on the
previous ones then let me take tons and
tons of data plus a few clever ideas of
a regularization to avoid overfitting
and then let me fit these models by
doing absolutely ridiculous amounts of
computation using graphics cards so let
me just essentially take old ideas lots
of data and super fast computers and I
can build amazing machine learning
models that's pretty much the story of
deep learning so I argue that we should
think in optimization along similar
lines and for lack of a better name I'm
going to call this deep optimization so
the the classical approach is to say you
know let's turn to an expert to design a
heuristic algorithm and let's
iteratively conduct small experiments to
figure out how to make our design better
and you know keep iterating until the
conference deadline gets closed and at
that point you know terminate send the
paper after the conference if it gets
rejected then repeat the deep
optimization approach basically mirrors
what we saw with deep learning so let's
take a very highly parameterised
algorithm to express a combinatorial
space of heuristic choices that an
expert might think makes sense so let's
use expert knowledge only to identify
parameters that might make sense in
isolation and let's make this deep in
the sense that there can be many layers
of parameters with each parameter
depending on the previous ones and let's
take again lots of data to characterize
a distribution of interest and let's
computationally search this space of
many algorithms instead of relying on
some notion of human insight so let's
think about algorithm design at least in
the heuristic sense as being you know
performed by gigantic scale simulation
by these tons of course that we have
lying around rather than thinking that
we have deep insight about how these
heuristics combinatorially interact with
each other and so I'm going to call this
kind of core building block that we're
going to need algorithm configuration
and so the input that we're going to be
given is it is some algorithm which is
parametrized by every design choice that
some human expert thought might possibly
make sense and it's going to be deep in
the sense that we have many layers of
parameters depending on parameters if I
have multiple algorithms that I've kind
of thought of that's a high level
parameter which says which algorithm do
I use and its own parameters depend on
that and so on yes the optimization I'm
gonna definition are just essentially
genetics algorithm you have to be
exactly this type of thing if you give
them a lot of women father you're just
doing essentially some kind of genetic
algorithm local searches a Chevy and at
the end date with Kindle why don't march
a way to here and the methods that i'm
going to propose but in fact people have
used genetic algorithms as a way of
building algorithm configurators not the
best methods around but they do work um
i have seen interactive
you okay yeah so I'm actually I with
some co-authors co-authored a local
search algorithm configurator called /
am I LS which is not genetic but it's
based on local search and it's pretty
good there's something else called GGA
which is gendered genetic algorithm
which is a the configurator it's less
good but also competitive so so
definitely this exists I want to tell
you about another approach called
Beijing optimization which is not local
search at all and which depends on these
kind of modeling ideas that we've been
talking about so so let me build to that
but but broadly speaking this whole kind
of vision of deep optimization sure
there's nothing telling you you can't
use a genetic algorithm to do this thing
just as you know ultimately deep
learning is about you know gradient
descent right I mean it not necessarily
saying these things have to be super
tricky but so what we want to do is
solve this stochastic optimization
problem of finding a parameter
configuration that has good performance
why is this stochastic because we're
looking only at a sample from the
instances and the algorithms themselves
can be randomized and this is a black
box function optimization problem
because we want to do this optimization
with reasoning about how the algorithm
works we're just going to evaluate the
algorithm at a given point and then
we're going to observe a runtime from
the algorithm and what we want to
minimize is some performance measure
that cares about runtime let's say
average runtime and that's this makes
this a really interesting black box
function optimization because you have
these crazy design dimensions they're
not all continuous you have this extra
dimension of which instance do I test
which you could always do it in random
but there might be smarter things to do
you might want to do a blocked
experiment design and you might start to
notice that some instance is always hard
and so maybe you're unlikely to learn
something from it the cost of gathering
a point is not constant the points that
you're looking for or fast and the fast
points are really cheap to observe and
so there's a sort of virtual cycle that
if you're doing well it's not costing
you much but if you look at a bad part
of the space it could cost you a ton to
observe how bad it is but you don't have
to run it to completion you can choose
to terminate it early that's a censored
sample but then you've learned less all
you've learned is that it's worse than
then whatever threshold you pick and so
you have this other design dimension
about how much
to censor the reason I belabor this is I
think this is a really exciting problem
in stochastic optimization and I know
the stochastic optimization is one of
the putative themes of the semester so I
want to put this up is this other sense
in which this work kind of interfaces
with the algorithms and uncertainty
theme here I wanted to sort of plant
this seed for you guys and but the the
best current methods for solving this
problem are based on the fact that it's
possible to make these runtime
predictions so let me tell you a little
bit how these methods work and so
there's this methodology called
sequential model based optimization that
goes back to work in the late 70s it's a
popular method for thinking about black
box function optimization mostly it's
being used for entirely continuous
functions that they don't have most of
the complications that I told you about
in the last slide you're sort of a
cartoon of how they work and so what I
do is I observe my function at a variety
of different points to begin with I do
some kind of initial experiment design
and then I fit a model to those points
that predicts for every value of my
parameters what happens so that's what
this solid line is this is my model
prediction and this dotted line is my
true objective so in this particular
cartoon that I'm drawing here there's no
noise whenever I observe at a point I
get the accurate value but then I can be
wrong in other places and here I'm in
this cartoon I'm fitting a Gaussian
process model which is what's typically
done in this literature and what's cool
about that what makes this beige in
optimization is that I get uncertainty
estimates from the model so the model is
pretty sure that it's right close to
points that it's observed before and it
gets pretty uncertain as it gets far
away from points that it's observed
before then we have an acquisition
function that says how good is it going
to be to look at a point in a particular
place and that cares both about how how
high the the predicted function is in
this place and how much variation there
is because you know it knows if there's
not much to be gained in these points
that have very small error bars for
example for these cartoons I am we've
experimented with them we again use
random forests but they make less pretty
pictures because they're piecewise
constant and so the intuitions are nicer
from Rome Gaussian processes and and so
then and the acquisition function is
maximized at this point so we were we
look at the acquisition function
everywhere which we have kind of offline
access to and that's not a black box we
maximize the acquisition function we
actually get a new data point and then
we refit our model to the new data point
and that gives us a new acquisition
function and then we keep doing this and
eventually you know we get to figure out
where the best we wear a function is
minimize looking at it everywhere um and
so this is a pretty promising approach
and notice that what makes it work is
that you've got the ability to make
predictions across your parameter space
which is what the first part of the talk
was basically about the fact that we can
do this when it comes to heuristic
algorithms in the spirit of the talks
that came before let me also notice that
there's a whole bunch of work on regret
bounds for these s MBL methods and
something I'm interested in talking with
people about later and here's a little
animation to show you a simulation of
how this actually looks and so I mean
maybe you could get it from the previous
picture but I think it's nice to sort of
see it happening and in a moving picture
so this this line here is our fit model
the dotted lines here are the error bars
around the model again we're noiseless
the blue line is the true function which
we only get to observe at the points
that we look at the red line is is the
point that we're looking at and here's
our acquisition function here which is
expected improvement so we're asking on
expectation given that the point I'm
looking at is better than the the
current minimum that we've seen
elsewhere how much better is it and
we're going to go look at the place that
is predicted to have the highest
expected improvement so let's watch this
thing go
that again okay I think it's going now
and so see how the error bar is start
tightening up the acquisition function
is jumping around and the model it
doesn't end up being correct everywhere
you know it's still pretty wrong out
here in the edges but after a while the
acquisition function is still maximized
around here and so it ends up just kind
of looking around this minimum um I
think it's about to just restart I'll
let it run one more time so you can just
see how this works of course we're doing
this in a high dimensional space this is
looking at one parameter and we're
looking at maybe hundreds of parameters
not all of which are continuous but
intuitively this is kind of how these
methods work so um they're really kind
of fundamentally driven by the ability
to make accurate predictions about run
time so the method that we've the
non-locals would method that my club
right collaborators and I have come up
with that I think at this point is kind
of indisputably the the best algorithm
configuration method out there is called
sequential model based algorithm
configuration or smack and it basically
and works more or less the way that I
described it works with random forest
models so it learns a random forest
model kind of as we just saw before in
this joint space of instances and
parameters so the the fact that we can
generalize to new instances and
parameters is very important we then
marginalize out the instance features to
get expected performance and we find a
parameter value that maximizes some
acquisition function in this case
expected improvement over our previous
incumbent and we actually go out and do
an algorithm run see what happens do an
incremental update of the model and we
just keep iterating until we run out of
time and so this is a really powerful
way of finding a new algorithms from
some known space of algorithms that
perform well and we've released this is
open source code that anyone can
download and use and it's been really
widely used both in industry and by
other academics and both by us and by a
whole bunch of other people if any of
you have a kind of practical frame of
mind this is something that you can
download and get working
really not that hard to use and kind of
the sky's the limit for what it what
it's good for its you know being used
for problems as varied as you're just
grinding away on competitions to
schedule in exams at UBC to improving
the performance of computer go or
protein folding or even making machine
learning algorithms work better so it's
a pretty general approach yeah what
category what exactly is it one um I
remember exactly what happened in SAT
with it but people have tuned other
people's algorithms in ways that have
caused them to then win right so it
isn't like we've designed the algorithm
our sovereign we're given the starting
point so so I'm trying to remember
exactly what it is about the sad
competition that led me to put that up
there I have to remember and actually
it's it's partly complicated by what I'm
going to tell you on the next slide
which also touches on the side
competition and so let me let me tell
you about that um which is um well maybe
somebody else has something they want to
say before I before I dodge that
question is anything else i live in
configuration yeah I parameter
optimization as well as others and
selection simultaneously or yes I
actually we've we've also extended this
to a problem and machine a machine
learning that I didn't mention here
we've built a package called auto Weka
that uses the same approach to solve the
problem of model selection and hyper
parameter optimization at the same time
so you know if you are a sort of machine
learning novice you download the the
Weka package which is basically one
piece of code that runs every machine
learning algorithm in the world they can
be configured to be every machine
learning algorithm anyone's ever heard
of just about you know you don't really
know where to begin so we've built
something that is integrated into Weka
you can download it from the Weka
package manager and you basically hit a
button that says start and it just
starts trying things and you use a smack
to reason about which machine learning
methods in Weka work well and you know
ends up finding for you both a model
family and a high parameters setting for
that model family they give you good
performance
I are you put into the young on the
space of height parameters and I think
we start with a uniform prior on just
kind of a ranges that made sense to us I
should mention that you know under the
hood dealing with overfitting is very
important there as it is really in the
algorithm case it's possible to overfit
an algorithm design just as it is in
machine learning it's really a machine
learning problem so a lot of what it
takes to make smack actually work
properly is to do a sort of significance
testing only making sure that we're not
becoming falsely confident that some
incumbent is better yeah so just
understand if I the for example
scheduling and resource occasion so if I
have some prohibitive of the salt right
should I go any good with the only like
an input different algorithms oh okay so
so typically you know so what it does is
you have to give it an algorithm that
you want to run that has many parameters
and you know you might in your case you
see Plex which I think we actually give
you a wrapper for C pod so we say she
plucks has last count I think 63
parameters that don't affect numerical
precision but affect just the strategy
used by cplex so give me a distribution
of input problems that have to do with
your scheduling domain give me cplex and
this see what rapper that knows what its
parameters are and i'm going to figure
out you know an instantiation of cplex
that is optimized to work well for your
problem that's what it does and you know
the thing is turns out there's lots of
stuff in the suplex design space that's
really good for one problem that isn't
good overall so it isn't the thing that
cplex exposed as the default so I think
we did a collaboration with c plus at
one point where we actually started
seeing 10,000 times speed ups on some of
the quiet problems that they gave us
which they weren't terribly surprised by
because they weren't trying to you know
do pointwise the best thing they were
trying to do well on average with their
default settings but there really is a
lot of scope for improvement by doing
this kind of thing but even if if we did
this perfectly as Tim alluded to in his
talk it's not necessarily going to be
the case that a single algorithm is
going to be the best thing to run on
every instance in a distribution we've
pretty robustly observed
there's there's no kind of best SAT
solver at least yet what we find is that
different solvers work well on different
sub parts of the distribution and that
these performance differences can be
pretty enormous and so there's another
way that we can see something we can do
from empirical hardness models if I have
the ability to make accurate runtime
predictions about how long a solver is
going to take to run then given some new
problem instance I've never seen before
I can run a model for every one of my
solvers see how long they're likely to
run and then run whichever one is
predicted to be fastest and if that if
the runtime differences are big that can
be a really big win that can end up you
know I can end up with the the min of
runtime zyk Ross the solvers rather than
the men of the averages and that could
be just a lot better and so we have been
in the site competition for years
entering something called SAT Zilla
which is graphically depicted here at a
sec competition in Tokyo and sat Zilla
does exactly this we take other people
SAT solvers and we sort of put them
together knowing kind of nothing about
how they work inside but just learning
models of them and we're able to
dramatically outperform other people SAT
solvers and so in fact we do something
more complicated than what I just told
you about empirical hardness models so
we've elaborated that them sat xela
quite a lot over the years so it can
work with randomized and incomplete
algorithms I had reasons about running
pre solvers for a short fixed time
before eventually picking something we
optimized for scoring functions other
than runtime and we do all of this in an
automatic way where we make decisions
about all of this we can think about all
these questions as should I have a pre
solver how long should it run for as
other parameters that we can think about
again using this kind of deep
optimization approach and if you think
about it for more than a minute you'll
notice that algorithm selection really
isn't a regression problem anymore what
I really care about is selecting among
us finite set of alternatives this
sounds like classification now the cost
of a classification error depends on the
run times which is why the runtime thing
still makes sense so using just kind of
regular ordinal classification is a bad
idea here but cost-sensitive
classification is a thing in machine
learning
and that makes sense because you know it
might very possibly be that the runtimes
are a complicated concept to learn but
the decision boundary the cost-sensitive
decision boundary between different cuts
all vers which one should I pick is a
much simpler concept to learn so and
we've had success using cost sensitive
classification and if you've got lots of
cores you don't even need to do that you
don't need to do selection at all you
can just run many things in parallel and
you know which everyone finishes first
so much the better for you um so sad
Zilla has taken the SAT world by storm
it in 2003 we did kind of a bad job as a
proof of concept when we came second and
third in a bunch of categories then I
got some grad students I got a job and
so we entered the 2007 2009 that
competitions and we won first in a lot
of categories and everyone got very
upset and in the 2012 SAT challenge
we're eligible to enter four categories
and we placed first first first second
you know with like dozens of entrance in
every category and then they said
competition people became so upset they
changed the rules to say that we
couldn't enter sad competitions anymore
and so this story ended but but I think
it ended with us having proven our point
that this is a good thing to do so I
think people in the SAT community are no
longer really in doubt that algorithm
portfolios are an effective approach huh
well technically baby love you havin a
little bit you know I mean the thing is
you know it's a cute yeah it's like they
say don't do this thing and it's exactly
the thing that I did then you know it's
it's bad behavior
you take the algorithms from that same
year that are you know we can't do that
but every previous year they have to
make them open source so we're always we
I mean otherwise it would almost be a
full in conclusion that we would win but
it's essentially our ability to select
among peoples last year ideas versus
whatever progress they made in the next
year and and you know we were and of
course here it's possible that the
selection is working badly that we make
bad selections and it would have been
better to just stick with one thing but
no typically not and and also the
incidence distributions change
arbitrarily adversarial II from year to
year they might be trying to trip us up
so the training data is not necessarily
iid anymore and but but nevertheless yet
we were doing okay until they shut us
down and I think you know the overall
message of the story is this was a
pretty robust approach um and so so I
was kind of happy almost that they
banned us because we get to stop doing
it was a lot of work every year I mean
yeah we sort of made our point and and I
think something that's kind of cool
about it is there are a lot of solvers
that people had decided just sort of
sucked like they they were really just
washing out in the competition and we
were really bringing the back because we
discovered that for like five percent of
instances you know you're solver is
amazing and the rest of the time it's
terrible but we can predict when it's
going to be amazing and use it only
there and all of a sudden you know it's
a really great thing whereas there was a
sort of hurting behavior in the sap
community where everyone cared about
average performance so they were all
doing relatively similar things and I
think I think there's something sort of
nice about the fact that we're bringing
back these kind of uncorrelated ideas
and again there's open source software
out there and you can use it for
problems other than said so so far what
I've told me about assumes that we start
with some manageable set of relatively
uncorrelated solvers you might um you
know if I really want to tie a ribbon
around this deep optimization idea let's
say all I start with is a huge deep
parameter space where maybe the
top-level perimeter is which solver
among many solver families do I use and
then each of them has their own crazy
space and let's say I want something
that works completely automatically but
that will produce a portfolio of as
uncorrelated as possible solvers
as its end result this is something that
we call Hydra we built an approach that
does this and basically it greedily
builds up a portfolio one solver at a
time by running configuration at each
stage and the way it works is that we
change the objective function between
from one stage to the next so it turns
out that smack doesn't care what
objective function you give it so we can
change on the second round we say we
take an idea from economics and think
about marginal contributions so we say
what I'm adding a second thing to to my
first solver I'm going to score it not
according to its own runtime but I'm
going to score it according to the
minimum of its runtime and the runtime
of the other solver and so anything it
does better it gets credit for anything
it does worse i'm just going to use the
other solver anyway so i don't care how
badly it does but all of its competitors
are able to get that same runtime too
and so then I'm asking kind of how much
are you improving average performance
through this kind of iterative
improvement and and this is a sub
modular objective function so I've so
greedy optimization makes sense here
this ends up working pretty well so I'm
almost out of time but but let me
finally get to the 88 billion dollar
number that that almost waved in front
of you like a red flag at the beginning
of the talk because we put all these
ideas together in the work that we did
for the FCC on the incentive option and
so actually the the projected profits
are more like 30 billion 8888 billion is
just one of the input numbers to this
whole thing but it's probably as little
as 30 billion in the end of the day and
but but yeah the way this is going to
work is that the federal government is
buying back from television stations
their right to broadcast they're going
to end up buying out roughly half of the
television stations in the United States
they're going to take that spectrum and
resell it to cell phone companies that
want to use it for more modern purposes
and they're going to take everybody else
who either they didn't choose to buy
from or who refused to sell and they're
going to change what frequencies they're
operating on so that they're operating
on some sub range of the frequency so
they get something clean to to sell and
this repacking problem of deciding it so
be baked into the option there's a
question of is it possible for me to
offer a lower price to some guy and in
order to decide that I need to decide is
it possible for me to put him back on
the air with this reduced band of
spectrum and with all the other people
that are already on the air right now
and without getting too much into the
details that's a graph coloring problem
with about 3,000 nodes in the graph
about 20 colors of me 15 colors and
about 3 million constraints between all
of the different stations on the scale
of the whole United States and so every
time I want to think about a price
movement of one of the three thousand
stations every single time to price
increments for one guy I need to solve
an np-complete problem and if I fail to
do it right if I want to solve one of
these problems but I don't I don't
manage to solve it then I'm leaving
money on the table the starting prices
or something like 10 million dollars and
you know when my first decision of we
can I go from 10 million dollars to 8
million dollars that depends on whether
I'm able to find a solution to a
satisfiability problem a satisfiability
encoding of a graph coloring problem and
if I fail that means it just cost me two
million dollars for that one problem and
this is real and our software is
actually running right now for the FCC
so this was a huge project that involved
many people let me just showed out
particularly to Neal Newman my PhD
student and Alexander flechette my
former PhD student who ran after Google
hi Alex many others a couple of
economist from Stanford Paul Milgram and
Elias ago we're kind of instrumental in
this as well it's a Holger and Frank and
help to drive some of this work as I
mentioned before and various people at
the FCC and so we gathered a bunch of
data and in over the past year using
simulations at the FCC and varying all
kinds of simulation assumptions which
never mind what all these things mean
but varying all kinds of questions about
how big was the auction going to be
who's going to participate how much are
they going to value it and when we
generated about one and a half million
instances from many auctions simulations
and what we wanted was to be able to
solve
all of these NP complete problems within
one minute because we have to do them
sequentially so one round of the auction
is grinding through three thousand
stations and we won round of the air we
can get about two rounds a day so I'm
just from what the client is willing to
put up with so given the variation run
times and so on we figured that we
really can't run any problem for more
than about a minute so the question was
how well can we do in a minute when we
started people were thinking about mixed
integer programming solvers and on are
so again we have training data and test
data everything that involved fitting
something we use the training data and
what I'm showing you here uses the test
data so on the x-axis here this is run
time from 10 to the minus 2 seconds up
to 1 minute here on a log scale and
here's the fraction of instances in our
test set that we were able to solve
within each amount of time so what you
would most like to see is a graph that
goes straight up and then stays there
but it's a cumulative density function
that would mean that I solved everything
within like less than a second and what
you're seeing here is that these two
state-of-the-art commercial MIPS solvers
are solving in one case about ten
percent in one case about a quarter of
the instances within a minute and that's
terrible that means but that doesn't
mean that we would get you know
twenty-five percent of the stations
right that means we would get
twenty-five percent of the price
movements many of which we would never
get to because we would have had to stop
earlier as soon as we had an unsolved
problem that station is done forever so
you couldn't run the auction with a
sulfur like this this would be way way
not good enough we looked at SAT solvers
and they haven't been thinking about SAT
and SAT solvers are a lot better so we
have the sub competition we have all
these different set solvers we tried
everything and and they're doing a lot
better our best thing a local search
solver called dcca is getting about
two-thirds of the instances solved
that's better but so two-thirds of the
price movements is not enough to run an
auction so then we started using the the
application ideas i told you about today
these various deep optimization ideas so
the first thing we looked at is we took
all of these solvers and we tried to
optimize them using smack and i'm
showing you here only the best one but
you know here's the soviet that used to
be best here's the solver clasp which is
a SAT solver from a team in germany that
is particularly well-suited to deep
ization would get as many many many
parameters and here's clasp after
configuration and just notice how it now
becomes by far the best thing way better
than it used to be still not good enough
to run an option with it now we're at
about three quarters of the instances so
then we use to Hydra so then we continue
doing this configuration to build a
portfolio of many different SAT solvers
with a variety of different heuristic
ideas that we have in ourselves which we
dis exposed as more parameters and this
is kind of our punch line we ended up
with a portfolio of eight different
solvers and and the performance which is
this red line here we're now solving
something like ninety-eight percent of
the instances within a minute and this
is what the FCC is actually running in
the auction and it makes a real
difference because if every time we fail
to solve a problem we're really causing
the US government to not collect money
for kind of no reason except
computational complexity so so I think
this is a good kind of practical example
of the fact that these these techniques
really work in practice so i'll leave it
there and thanks to all of you for your
attention so you talked about using the
prediction of run time to pick whichever
one would give you the shortest one time
and i'm wondering if like every sat
heuristic needs to both be able to say
when there's a satisfying instance and
proof when there's not and i'm wondering
if you design two separate things one
that was good for proving satisfiability
when those good for proving that
something is unsatisfiable and then
using your prediction of whether or not
something is how to seibel how you would
do that have you looked that's a good
idea so actually am we did something
sort of like that here if my they're
going to turn this off already we did
something sort of like that here you'll
notice if I look at the names of the
solvers we actually have a portfolio of
two algorithm families on satin Stein
which I didn't tell you what it is but
it's basically a family of local search
solvers that we built ourselves that
sort of you know the sort of convex
combination of every local search sad
idea anybody ever had in one code base
so that you can sort of stitch them
together and make crazy new local search
solvers local search is particularly
well
to this because the idea sort of
composed pretty easily and and so all of
these saben Stein solvers our local
search which means they can't prove
unset so they really are optimized for
satisfiability I didn't tell you this
either but it turns out in this auction
domain most of the problems are
satisfiable because most of the time
they're making price movements where
once I encounter a guide that causes an
unsatisfiable problem I freezes price
forever and I don't see him anymore of
the problems so there's a tendency to
kind of hit one end side problem and
then can veer away from that part of the
space so we spend most of our time with
on sale with satisfiable instances which
is why these guys predominate we do have
a couple of complete solvers which allow
us to prove unsat so in that sense we're
doing something sort of like you said
something more explicit like what you
proposed might make sense except we had
so little unsat data here that wouldn't
have gained as much in this application
but another one that might matter yeah
why stopping problems in energy so there
are lots of important piece based heart
problems that people have worked on
heuristics for ages on so does your
framework need for example 6 inc its or
what what it's not at all no i mean you
know we don't have succinct certificates
with unset problems for example anyway
right really what we need is run time
variation so if you have problems where
every problem in the distribution takes
pretty much the same amount of time to
run there's very little to be gained I'm
not saying that's going to be true for
every problem in peace base i'm just
saying that that's really the thing that
that means that you're going to gain
something with these approaches
otherwise I think it's just kind of an
accident of the the sorts of problems
that you know in my day job I'm a kind
of game theory person we just run into a
lot of these sort of np-complete
discrete optimization problems in
thinking about game theory so I've been
sort of naturally focused on those
problems but there's really nothing to
make us think about that I people have
used the I people have extended some of
this stuff even to like sorting problems
for example trying to there's like
certain choices about sorting algorithms
where you can get your not exponential
variation in run times but still sort of
meaningful variation run times and you
can make selection choices there people
you know shown that you can even do
something in those sorts of settings so
I think that was a big win but that
shows that you're certainly not limited
to NP complete problems alright thanks
everybody I believe